Hella von denen es gibt eine sehr
prominente Stimme im Moment in der
Politik die auch genau das sagt Sahra
Wagenknecht sie hat eine sehr
umstrittene Rede im Bundestag gehalten
und sie sagt aktuell auch das nämlich
dass die Interessen der Menschen in der
Ukraine angeblich und da bezieht sie
sich auch auf die Worte der
Außenministerin ja mehr zählen würden
als die Interessen vieler Deutschen ich
nehme an die Meinung ist Konsens im
Hause
sie sehen das völlig richtig ich würde
mich überhaupt nicht wagen hier zu
widersprechen aber Scherz beiseite die
Kernfrage ist doch die wie können wir
den Menschen in Deutschland helfen
und das ist ja von der Mitteldorf
angesprochen weil er hat gesagt wir
müssen die Frage beantworten ob wir mit
Russland Überlieferung von Energie
verhandelt nun kann man sagen wie die
Bundesregierung oder andere oder die
sich nicht trauen oder zu feige sind
nein machen wir nicht wir wollen den
Putin bestrafen das kann man alles
machen dann sage ich dann bleiben die
Energiepreise aus marktgründen wenn die
russischen Mengen nicht kommen bleiben
auf sehr hohem Niveau und damit sind
diejenigen die die russischen Mengen
ablehnen Schuld für die hohen Preise die
Menschen in Deutschland begreifen das
langsam kürzlich hat Insa ermittelt dass
die Öffnung von 192 von einer Mehrheit
der Menschen mittlerweile als für
richtig gehalten wird weil die Menschen
ja sehen alle Päckchen die geschnürt
werden gehen nicht auf das eigentliche
Problem und das eigentliche Problem ist
nach wie vor wie kriegen wir die
Gaspreise runter wer einen besseren Weg
hat als die Verhandlung mit Russland der
Soli nennen aber bisher haben wir eben
nur Vorschläge gehört die alle nicht
positionieren das Sessel auf Flüssiggas
ist Angesicht der Preislage geradezu
absurd das heißt sie würden im Moment
heller fontainer ein bisschen Richter
verstanden wenn sie in der Rolle wären
nach Moskau reisen
selbstverständlich würde ich eben
Verhandlungen aufnehmen denn wir werden
auf Dauer ich sage das in aller Klarheit
es geht nicht nur um Gas oder Öl die in
deutsche Industrie wird auf Dauer ohne
russische Rohstoffe nicht bestehen
können wir werden das in den nächsten
Monaten drastisch vor Augen geführt
bekommen Herr Hofreiter ihre
Außenministerin lehnt das kategorisch ab
lehnt dieses Gespräch mit Herr la from
ab herr Scholz telefoniert mit Herrn
Putin lehnt aber diese Verhandlungen ab
das ist im Moment in der Regierung
absolut Konsens werden wir wird ihre
Regierung zu diesem Punkt kommen wenn
die Gaspreise eben unbezahlbar sind wenn
der Druck von der Straße massiv wird
nein selbstverständlich werden wir dem
Kriegsverbrecher nicht weitere Geld in
den Rachen stopfen und man muss halt
wieder sagen und es ist halt dann billig
zu sagen dass das Polymer Moment
Christian mehr Geld in den Drachen
also nicht mal reden sondern der Punkt
ist wenn sie Nord Stream 2 aufmachen wir
haben drei Pipelines es gibt überhaupt
keine Sanktionen auf Gas ich hielt dir
die für sinnvoll aber es gibt und 3 x 0
ist 0 und 4 mal 0 ist halt auch null das
ist simpelste Mathematik und das kann
man halt auch verstehen aber wenn man
halt ideologisch völlig verbohrt ist
dann will man es halt einfach
erschlichtig nicht verstehen und
deswegen muss man halt dafür dass wir
heute die russischen Energien es bleibt
die Frage und da sind sie auf dem Weg
der wird nur langfristig erst erfolgen
oder mittelfristig erfolgen es bleibt
die Frage nach der Gewichtung wenn eben
hier der Wohlstand verloren geht und die
Menschen fragen warum dreht ihr nicht
einfach an dem gashähnchen warum löst
ihr nicht zuerst mein Energieproblem
mein Kostenproblem und dann kümmert ihr
euch um die Ukraine was antworten Sie
erstens weil es dazu führen würde dass
der russische Krieg gegen die Ukraine
wahrscheinlich länger dauern würde und
damit die Probleme länger dauern weil
wir dann die Kriegsmaschine noch mal
stärker mit Geld füttern würden zweitens
weil es gar nicht in der Hand haben weil
nämlich die Sanktionen gar nicht gegen
russisches Erdgas erlassen worden sind
die gibt's nämlich
damit nämlich die Bedingung von Putin
ist wir hören auf die Ukraine zu
unterstützen das muss man einmal ganz
klar sagen man kann mit Putin darüber
verhandeln aber die Bedingung ist wir
liefern keine Waffen mehr an die Ukraine
und werfen die Ukraine einem
faschistoiden System zum Fraß vor das
ist die Bedingung das heißt Herr
Lafontaine sagt hier ich will für
billiges Gas dass die russische Armee in
der gesamten Ukraine Morgen und
vergewaltigen darf das ist sozusagen das
was er von der Regierung verlangt und
das muss man mit der Klarheit sagen und
ich glaube wenn Sie die Leute fragen
würden wollen Sie wirklich für billiges
Erdgas das in der Ukraine Kinder
vergewaltigt werden und es hätte wäre
die Konsequenz wenn er keine Waffen mehr
die Vermögen würden die Leute nein sagen
deswegen müssen wir trotzdem mehr tun um
die Leute zu unterstützen für die
Übergangsphase wo die Energiepreise so
hoch sind das bestreite ich überhaupt
nicht und das werfe ich unsere Regierung
auch mit vor und uns allen die wir
Verantwortung tragen das wird auch nicht
schnell genug sein denn sie haben völlig
recht dem Rentner hilft nichts wenn er
heute zahlen muss wenn in zwei Monaten
da heller von der Preis Deckel darauf
ja das ist eben das Gerede der Grünen
seit längerem aber sie sind ja mehr oder
weniger jetzt an die Wand gelaufen ihre
Vorwürfe würden Japan und Frankreich
treffen das ist so absurd die werfen die
Ukraine in Russen zum Fraß vor die
Japaner haben mehr in der Birne als wir
die wissen dass ihre Industrie Energie
brauchen das gilt eben auch für uns die
Grünen werden es auch noch begreifen
unsere Industrie braucht Energie und mit
Gerede und mit irgendwelchen
putinenverstehen Geschwätz ist da
überhaupt nicht geregelt ohne russische
Rohstoffe und Energie können wir unseren
Wohlstand nicht erarbeiten und deshalb
muss ich Ihnen sagen sie werden
mitverantwortlich sein für den
Niedergang der deutschen Wirtschaft und
die Verarmung weiter Teiler der
Bevölkerung kehren sie um es gibt keinen
anderen Weg
ganz kurz die Unwahrheit wird nicht
dadurch wahrer wenn man sie wiederholt
Herr La Fontaine ich habe ihn schon
einmal gesagt es gibt gar keine
Sanktionen
das haben wir verstanden der Hofreiter
Herr Middelhoff stimmt das ohne
russisches Gas ist es zwangsläufig der
Niedergang unseres Wohlstands der
Niedergang unserer Industrie ich würde
zunächst mal vorschlagen dass wir uns
auf das konzentrieren das was wir aus
deutscher Sicht machen können und
gestalten können das ist die
Laufzeitverlängerung der AKWs ja also
kommt stattdessen reden wir über und
Dings da muss man auch erst weiter so
ein bisschen die Kirche im Dorf lassen
auch bei der Argumentation also das ist
erstmal eine klare Entscheidung eine
klare Message was zumindest mal
Planungsgrundlagen hervorruft dann kann
man hingehen und sagen über welches
Delta sprechen wir hier eigentlich wenn
wir auf der einen Seite wenn wir auf der
einen Seite richtig wenn wir auf der
einen Seite dann einen preisdeckel haben
dann wissen wir erstmal so kommen wir
einigermaßen vor allen Dingen für die
einkommensschwachen über die Runden vor
allen Dingen die Industrie kann weiter
planen so und das nächste ist das was
Herr lafontain gesagt hat ich halte es
nicht für ausgeschlossen dass man das
eine und das andere nicht lassen kann
nämlich dass man eine moralische
Position hat aber gleichzeitig den Zwang
hat und die Verpflichtung aus auch wenn
sie das nicht hören wollen Herr
Hofreiter aus einem amtsalt heraus und
aus der politischen Verpflichtung heraus
alles dafür zu tun dass die Energie die
übrigens auch die Industrie braucht er
gebe ich einen davon den Recht bekommt
denn Experten waren ja längst von dem
Blackout und das sind nicht mehr
irgendwelche Spinner sondern das sind
diejenigen die das einfach dieses Delta
wie Herr mittelhoff ausrechnen also das
Problem ist doch
wir streiten jetzt sehr stark über
diesen Weg der im Augenblick noch in
keiner Weise begangen ist von der
handelnden Regierung es sind ja nur
Vorschläge da es ist ja noch nichts in
der Umsetzung noch mal
wenn Sie mit den Unternehmern reden
Hofreiter müssen Sie nicht mit dem Kopf
schütteln reden sie in ihrem Wahlkreis
mit Unternehmen das tun sie sicher auch
dann sagen die ihnen wir haben im Moment
noch keine panikbezüglich dieser Energie
Situation aber wir haben mehr und sagen
Sie das so in der Sendung haben sie
gesagt wir haben mehr als große Sorgen
was die Energiesituation angeht wir
haben 7000 energieintensive Unternehmen
mit einer Million Jobs in Deutschland
ich meine das dürfen wir nicht vergessen
ich würde auch in ihre Richtung
argumentieren sagen im Augenblick fehlt
mir noch die Fantasie
wegen der Energiefrage mich mit Putin an
einen Tisch zu setzen das kann ich mir
im Moment nicht vorstellen es ist auch
genug Moral er ist ja er ist aber im im
aller long mittelfristig auszuschließen
wäre naiv Geld Moral ja politisch naiv
und es wäre auch gefährlich deshalb ist
diese überleg die Herr Mittelhof
angesprochen hat absolut natürlich
wenn ich einmal sticheln darf bei ihnen
dauert das länger weil sie eine gute
Pension haben weil sie ihn gut geht bei
den Menschen die im Moment auf der
Straße sind ging das schneller weil die
bereits an der Grenze sind die können
die stromabschlagszahlung nicht mehr
zahlen die Gas Abstandszahlung bei den
killt Geldbeutel
rufen sondern nur perspektivisch mir
vorstellen dass es mir durchaus
vorstellbar ist dass es im Herbst
durchaus zu Demonstrationen gut gemeint
gut gemeint kommt nicht vom rechten und
vom Rand das ist dazu noch in einem ganz
anderen Umfang kommt und darauf muss ich
Politik vorbereiten und darauf haben wir
längst auf der Straße
wir gehen direkt dorthin heute zum
Beispiel nach Freiberg im Sachsen wieder
eine Montagsdemonstration das was wir
mittlerweile seit Wochen seit Monaten
erleben und mit dabei unsere
bildreporterin Clara Marie Becker in
Freiberg auf der Straße was das war der
heute los was haben die Leute gesagt und
wer war dort auf der Straße
genau Kai heute haben auch hier in
Freiberg wieder hunderte Menschen um
genau zu sein 600 Menschen auf der
Straße demonstriert bei den sogenannten
Montagsdemos da gehen ja wirklich
mittlerweile um die Tausende oder
mehrere Tausende auf die Straßen hier in
ganz Sachsen und hier in Freiberg waren
heute wirklich Menschen die von ihren
persönlichen Problemen erzählt haben
keine Rechtsextremisten keine
Linksextremisten Menschen die einfach
Probleme haben im alltäglichen Leben und
das jetzt schon spüren wer meine Familie
getroffen die gesagt hat wir haben jetzt
wieder neue Rechnungen zugeschickt
bekommen wir wissen nicht mehr wie wir
die bezahlen sollen die Stromrechnung
ist in die Höhe geschossen wir haben
Menschen getroffen die erzählt haben
oder uns gefragt haben wir wissen
inzwischen nicht mehr wo wir hingehen
sollen mit unserem Frust deswegen gehen
wir hier auf die Straße wir wissen nicht
mehr wie wir unseren Unmut kundtun
sollen wie wir unsere Probleme nach
außen tragen sollen und was wir halt
ganz häufig gehört haben immer wieder
die Frage warum kümmern sich die
Politiker mehr um die Menschen in der
Ukraine also um uns hier in Freiberg das
sind die Fragen ob man die mag oder ich
danke Klara Mary Becker für diesen
interessanten Einblick heute nach
Freiberg in Sachsen das war nur eine von
ganz vielen Demonstrationen allein heute
abend man mag die mögen oder nicht diese
Fragen das sind die Fragen die im Moment
kommen Herr Hofreiter wie lange halten
Sie Ihren Kurs durch bis 5 Millionen
Arbeitslose bis zum ersten längeren
Blackout bis die Autoindustrie am Boden
ist was ist der Punkt wo sie
nicht mehr argumentieren können
in sanktionskurs und das ist natürlich
halt einfach Quatsch was sie erzählt
doch mit Nein
nämlich es stimmt schlichtig nicht wir
sind dabei flüssiggastherminals zu bauen
innerhalb von Monaten ja das ist mit
ihrer Geschwindigkeit wir sind gerade
dabei an ganze Reihe von alten
Kohlekraftwerken wieder ins Netz zu
bringen wir haben ein riesen
Gesetzespaket zu Beschleunigung des
Ausbaus das Erneuerbaren das haben wir
alles gehört lassen wir uns die Zeit
nutzen tatsächlich über diese Fragen zu
reden das Problem ist wenn sie Problem
nicht wenn ich hier behauptet wird die
Regierung hat an und dann vorgeschlagen
wird genau das zu machen und dann ist
der Plan in vielen Teilen bereits
Gesetzeskraft geworden dann stimmt es
halt nicht und es hilft auch sozusagen
nichts ist immer wieder zu wiederholen
weil nämlich vieles ist bereits
Gesetzeskraft vieles ist bereits im Bau
manche Kohlekraftwerke laufen hier
nochmal und von den drei Atomkraftwerken
werden wird im Herbst oder im Dezember
entschieden nämlich im Süden brauchen
wir die unter Umständen ob sie
weiterlaufen oder nicht und das heißt
wir tun bereits wahnsinnig viel
innerhalb sehr sehr kurzer Zeit und was
ich schon gesagt habe für die Leute die
gerade ihre Rechnungen kaum mehr
bezahlen können müssten wir und das
finde ich auch problematisch nicht nur
das was alles bereits beschlossen worden
ist dass die Leute mehr Geld kriegen das
Pakete gibt für Rentner Pakete für
Studierende sie haben zum Beispiel die
energieintensive Energie angesprochen da
gibt es bereits sozusagen auch
entsprechende Maßnahmen mit den
Unternehmen
ja auch ein strompreisdeckel und was ich
wie gesagt selber schon gesagt habe ja
wir bräuchten in meinen Augen schneller
einen Strompreis und gaspreisdeckel das
ist das was ich selber kritisiere was
wir auf uns nehmen müssen wo ich Werbung
dafür mache dass das so schnell wie
möglich passiert
wie möglich was heißt das ich bin nicht
ganz alleine an der Regierung ich bin
sogar gar nicht an der Regierung sondern
ich bin Ausschussvorsitzender im
Parlament aber das nur am Rande ich
sagte ich mache Werbung dafür dass es so
schnell wie möglich passiert aber hier
so zu tun als wenn eine Regierung die
eingesetzt nach dem anderen
verabschiedet und die Probleme doch sie
stellen ausgerechnet die Atomkraftwerke
nach vorne die Entscheidung hat nur
wirklich extrem lange gedauert aber wir
streiten gleich weiter darüber einmal
kurz Herr la von Themen bevor wir ganz
kurze Pause massiert
diese Regierung die Herr Hofreiter
gerade noch mal lobt weil ein wie er
sagt Gesetz nach dem nächsten kommt wird
die überhaupt noch das nächste Jahr
erleben der Druck in der Regierung ganz
massiv der Druck von der Straße ist
mittlerweile wie wir gerade gesehen
haben massiv
wenn sie nicht umkehren und einsehen
dass ihr Weg falsch ist werden sie große
Schwierigkeiten haben in einigen Monaten
die ganze Verzweiflung sieht man ja auch
daran dass sie jetzt in Aserbaidschan
anklopfen über die Europäische
Kommission dass die dann Gas liefern das
Pech ist nur das Aserbaidschan eben auch
ein völkereswidrigen Angriffskrieg führt
man sieht also dass die Regierung sich
hoffnungslos verrannt hat halten sie
Neuwahlen für ausgeschlossen
ich halte sie nicht für ausgeschlossen
wenn es nicht gelingt eben die soziale
Lage in Deutschland zu verbessern und
man muss daran erinnern dass das erste
Pflicht der deutschen Politik ist sich
um die Menschen hierzu kümmern die jetzt
in großer Not sind wenn das nicht
gelingt halte ich es für möglich dass
eben es immer instabiler wird in
Deutschland Neuwahlen Hofreiter nicht
mehr ausgeschlossen angesichts dieser
Stimmungslage ist es natürlich alles
Quatsch also wissen Sie ich habe ja
schon häufig Herrn Schulz kritisiert
aber wenn man halt vollkommen maßlos den
Teufel an die Wand malt ganz FDP gibt es
genau diese absatzbewegung erste
Kreisverbände sagen beispielsweise
Stralsund wir machen das nicht mehr mit
das hat Gründe mit der corona-krise aber
auch Gründe weil die Unternehmen Druck
machen an der Basis ich habe ja wie
gesagt schon gesagt dass man da auch
noch einiges tun muss wir sind ja auch
da noch lange zum am Ende aber wenn man
halt so völlig maßlos kritisiert und
dann zwingt man ja sogar jemand wie mich
der einen durchaus gemischten Blick auf
das Regierungshandeln aber plötzlich
Scholz über den grünen Klee zu loben
wobei ich einige Punkte hätte wo er
besser kommunizieren müsste wo er in
meinen Augen besser entscheiden müsste
nämlich zum Beispiel endlich auch Panzer
an die Ukraine zu liefern dass dieser
Krieg schneller zu Ende geht und so
weiter aber wenn man halt so wirklich
völlig maßlos agiert also dann würden
immer stimmen völlig maßlos weiß ich
absolut zurück auf Freitag wenn man
Fakten schildert ja dann ist das nicht
Maßlosigkeit sondern wir versuchen zu
analysieren wie die Situation ist welche
Ursachen
nimmt das Wort Inflation noch nicht mal
in welche Ursachen ist hat und heute die
Bundesbank hat gemeldet im nächsten Jahr
Inflationsrate zweistellig ich bin jetzt
fast 70 Jahre alt ja ich habe eine
zweistellige Inflationsrate nie erlebt
in meinem Leben und ich muss sagen hätte
man das vor 20 oder 25 Jahren
kommuniziert es werden Aufstand durch
die Republik gegangen ja das ist die
beste Rezession das ist es gibt eine
Korrelation zwischen Inflationsraten und
Arbeit das ist die Taste Rezession die
Deutschland hat